jim ich freue mich dass wir uns gefunden
habt der krieg in syrien ist noch lange
nicht vorbei aber trotzdem hat er heute
ein prozess in genf begonnen der kant
für die zukunft des landes ganz schön
bestimmend sein denn dort ist zum ersten
mal die verfassungskommission
zusammengekommen die sollte das sagt der
name für das land eine neue verfassung
finden allerdings sind nicht alle dabei
die in syrien leben und dort was zu
sagen haben einige richtige kurdische
vertreter zum beispiel dürfen nicht
dabei sein auf druck aus der türkei
daran kann man jetzt schon sehen dass
die kunden dann doch wahrscheinlich die
größten verlierer in syrien krieg sind
dabei sei das eigentlich für die eine
ganze zeit war ziemlich gut aus aber das
blatt hat sich in den letzten zwei
wochen ziemlich schnell und ziemlich
heftig gegen die kurden in nordsyrien
gesendet und was da passiert ist und was
da jetzt weiter passieren kann
darüber spreche ich heute mit den
deutsch jüdischen journalisten sieren
hossein und wer ihn nicht kennt das
werden die meisten von euch sein
für den übergang mal ein kleines porträt
zusammengestellt
[Musik]
das war vor vier wochen wenige tage vor
der türkischen militärintervention in
nordsyrien als der radiosender fm noch
über den alltag in der kurdenregion
berichtete und nicht über krieg
sie ruhen hussein ist der gründer von
afm er ist kurde und hat einen deutschen
pass
wenn man glaube ich denke schon dass sie
nennen sich die stimme der hoffnung
wollten eigentlich nie über die große
politik berichten doch die das überhaupt
so nah an der türkischen grenze und
simon hossein ist für uns in genf
zugeschaltet beobachtet dort genau diese
verfassungskommission die sicht heute
konstituiert hat sie leben in armut und
in bochum wenn ich richtig informiert
bin ist am oude für sie immer noch der
sicherste platz der welt in meinem
herzen ist der mutter immer noch dass
ich dass der platz auf der welt ich bin
letzten donnerstag
letzten donnerstag aus armut gekommen um
nach genf zu kommen um mehr über die
über die aktivitäten hier zu berichten
es wird da eine neue verfassung
angestrebt aber mutter ist leider jetzt
ein ort geworden der bedroht ist
die menschen haben dort angst weil die
türkei diesen frieden denn wir hatten
jetzt gestört hatte und die türkei hat
kein interesse daran dass armut weiter
hinter sich das sonst auf der welt
bleibt
wir bleiben noch mal ganz kurz bei
dieser verfassungskommission die sie
jetzt in genf beobachten können sie ganz
kurz mal zusammenfassen was da heute
passiert ist
heute sind die mitglieder der
verfassungskommission zusammengekommen
und die vereinten nationen haben
offiziell den beginn der gespräche
verkündet mehr ist da heute nichts
passiert
jetzt sind aber von den 150 vertretern
aus syrien die da zusammenkommen um über
eine neue verfassung zu beraten gerade
mal zwei kurven dabei wichtige vertreter
der kurden nämlich von der partei der
demokratischen union oder abgekürzt pd
die dürfen nicht dabei sein außen auf
auslegen druck aus der türkei
was kann das jetzt für den effekt haben
auch auf die verfassung und werden sich
die kunden denn überhaupt an dieser
fassung gebunden fühlen wenn jetzt schon
klar ist wichtige vertreter dürfen gar
nicht mitreden
nicht nur vertreter der kurden sind
nicht dabei sondern auch der anderen
minderheiten der christen der araber in
der region sind fünf bis sieben
millionen dem östlichen
gebiet von dem euphrat fluss leben
sie sind gar nicht vertreten ja es sind
zwar wie sie richtig gesagt haben zwei
kunden dabei sie sind in der gruppe der
opposition aber diese position wird von
der türkei toleriert und unterstützte
und die türkei hat keine presse dass die
richtigen vertreter der menschen in der
region hier vertreten sind sei es der pd
oder auch andere parteien
es gibt viele andere parteien nicht nur
die pt in der region aber heißt das denn
jetzt das die kunden in der region dann
hinterher sagen werden sorry das ist
nicht meine verfassung und tristan doch
wieder neue konflikte gibt obwohl man ja
versucht die gerade auszuräumen
das ist nicht nur eine verfassung für
die kunden sondern für die meisten syrer
weil die richtigen vertreter des
syrischen volkes sind heute gar nicht da
die personen die heute hierhin gefahren
sie wurden ausgesucht vom syrischen
regime von russland von von der türkei
und den wurden willkürlich ausgesucht
das heißt nur bestellte person hier da
gewesen also keine richtigen vertreter
der syrischen zivilgesellschaft vor
allem konnte man hier heute nicht sehen
also ich gucke schon mal in die
kommentare da ist es entsprechend dieses
jedoch sehr emotionalen themas für
manche auch relativ emotional und hier
gibt es so einige also eine userin
spricht sich sehr vehement gegen die
kurden aus sagt man solle den waffen
wegnehmen
die hätten da nichts zu sagen und werden
quasi die trieb skrei treiber in der
region
andere sprechen sich für solidarität mit
den kurden aus da sind sie es
wahrscheinlich als kurdische journalist
ein wenig befangen aber trotzdem noch
mal die frage welche verantwortung haben
die kurdischen milizen wenn ich das mal
aufgreifen kann für die er die
militärische situation dort in
nordsyrien die kunden und die anderen
minderheiten in der region haben den
letzten sieben jahre friedlich
zusammengelebt sie haben die
gefährlichste terror organisation in der
welt des besiegte die kunden waren nie
eine bedrohung für die türkei haben nie
eine bedrohung für die türkei
dargestellt die türkei hat auf einmal
sich entschieden die region anzugreifen
und viele tausende von menschen aus
ihren städten vertrieben
viele sind dabei umgekommen andere
verletzte viele andere gefangen
das heißt es war die türkei die diesen
krieg begonnen hat
ohne grund ohne dass es wirklich einen
grund dafür gibt dann müssen wir glaube
ich auch mal ganz kurz dazu sagen so
weit wir wissen gab es tatsächlich auch
keine angriffe aus diesen nordsyrischen
gebiet auf das gebiet der türkei und
auch der außenminister heiko maas hat
gesagt dass das was die türkei dort
gemacht hat nicht mit dem völkerrecht in
einklang steht von daher ist es eine
durchaus schwierige situation was mich
erst mal interessieren würde herr
aussehen wie war denn das leben
eigentlich vor dem bürgerkrieg dort in
nordsyrien die haben da kurden und
christen und palästinenser und araber
und was ist da alles noch so gibt
miteinander gelebt ja sie haben eine
institution aufgebaut die vorher nicht
war vorher war alles kontrolliert aus
damaskus zentralistisch auf einmal haben
die menschen selber versucht ihre
eigenen institutionen aufzubauen die
zivilgesellschaft hat viel getan
man hat friedlich zusammengelebt muslime
christen jesiden kurden araber und auch
andere ethnien und religiösen gruppen
die da eine region sind das heißt es war
eine region die wie die sicherste
überhaupt in syrien war pressefreiheit
war vorhanden
die menschen die wirtschaft hat geboomt
es gab viele unternehmen die entstanden
sind die mädchen hatten eine perspektive
vor ort und viele haben sich entschieden
dort zu bleiben gerade weil die region
friedlich fahren weil man weil man weil
der krieg weit weg war auf einmal ist
man mitten im krieg und die perspektive
die die menschen hatten ist nicht mehr
vorhanden und viele werden sich
überlegen ob sie da bleiben oder sich
oder fliehen aus dem land richtung
irakisch kurdistan oder auch nach europa
der seit 2011 ist hat auch einiges
passiert in der region und für uns
außenstehende die das noch von außen
beobachten können war das teilweise ja
auch ziemlich unübersichtlich was da
passiert ist deswegen haben wir jetzt
gar nicht erst versucht die letzten acht
jahre zusammen zu fassen
der dia thomas hat sich einfach nur mal
dieses jahr angeguckt und fast wir uns
zusammen was dort in syrien passiert ist
was 2011 in syrien als bürgerkrieg
beginnt wird wenig später auch zu einem
kampf gegen die terrorgruppe islamischer
staat und zu einem konflikt mit immer
mehr internationalen player
so ist die macht im herbst 2009 10
verteilt us-truppen beherrschen den
südwesten des landes der diktator wird
nach wie vor von russland unterstützt
die verschiedenen rebellengruppen haben
deutlich an einfluss verloren
kurdische kämpfer haben als maßgeblicher
teil der sogenannten demokratischen
kräfte syriens gemeinsam mit den us
truppen im nordosten erfolgreich die
terroristen des bekämpft
am 17 oktober ziehen die usa ihre
truppen mit relativ überraschend aus dem
gebiet zurück daraufhin beginnt die
türkei dort eine offensive gegen die
kurdischen kämpfer erdogan hat ein
klares ziel er will die kurdischen
kämpfer der gpg aus dem grenznahen
gebiet vertreiben und eine über 450
kilometer lange und über 30 kilometer
tiefe schutzzone errichten
in dieser situation bitten die kurden us
truppen um hilfe schließlich ist es ein
angriff der türkei auf syriens assad
truppen kommen unterstützt von den
russen
es ist ihre chance hier wieder macht und
einfluss zu gewinnen am 22 oktober
vereinbaren erdogan und putin zu
nordsyrien erdogan bekommt seine gpg
freie pufferzone der teil zwischen den
städten tablett und ras alpin wird vom
türkischen militär bewacht auch in den
übrigen gebiet darf das türkische
militär nahe an der grenze patroullieren
einsatztruppen und das russische militär
übernehmen jedoch die kontrolle
die großen verlierer der aktuellen
ereignisse die kurven und über die lage
der kurden in nordsyrien spreche ich
heute mit dem deutsch kurdischen
journalisten zero dann holte ihn da ist
gerade in genf beobachtet dort die
verfassungskommission die sich gerade
gebildet hat um für sie eine neue
verfassung zu bilden hier herrsche ihnen
sind jetzt schon auf youtube einige
kritische kommentare zum beispiel missio
garfield der schreibt warum verliere
also warum sein die kurden verlierer wie
wir das ja auch angeteasert haben sie
haben mit hilfe der amis ein drittel
syriens völkerrechtswidrig besetzt und
genau das dritte wo die erdölvorkommen
syriens liegen also hier quasi der
vorwurf das sind keine verlierer die
haben sich ein großes stück land unter
den nagel gerissen wo sie nichts zu
suchen haben und genau das fonds viel
geld zu holen gibt was sagen sie dazu
die kurden haben diese region befreit
dort waren bis vor einigen vor kurzer
zeit die gefährlichste
terrororganisation der welt und da ist
die kunden haben mit ihren partnern mit
ihren christlichen partnern mit den
arabischen partnern mit einheimischen
sie haben diese region befreit und da
ist noch nicht vorbei
die gefahr besteht weiterhin es gibt
weiterhin viele schwer verziehen und die
präsenz der syrisch demokratischen
kräfte sds dort ist sehr wichtig da sagt
das sagen nicht nur die amerikaner
sondern auch die europäer
viele tausende mitglieder kämpfer sind
weiterhin dort in den gefängnissen es
gibt dort kampf
über 80.000 innen hohl sind angesiedelt
das heißt die kunden tragen dazu bei
dass dort frieden herrscht dass dort
keine terrororganisation mehr die macht
in der hand hat aber ist da was dran
dass dort die größten erdölvorkommen in
syrien sind und dass die kurden davon
dann auch monetär profitiert haben
könnten
es gibt dort erdöl auf jeden fall aber
die kunden profitieren davon natürlich
aber auch der syrische staat profitiert
davon
alle menschen die in der region sind
alle auch die die araber profitieren
davon die christen profitieren davon
dass das ist sicher da sind ölfelder die
in syrien sind die gehirn den syrern und
das ist normal dass sie davon
profitieren dass sie meinen dass heute
die kurden zu reduzieren ist dann nicht
als legitim
das ist nicht legitim auf jeden fall
jetzt haben wir gerade gesehen also das
stimmt ja zumindest dass die kunden mit
unterstützung der usa dort tätig waren
und denise wie wir es in deutschland
nennen sie sagen da ist das ist eher der
syrisch arabische name jedoch geschafft
haben denen in zaum zu halten
beziehungsweise auch aus der region zu
verdrängen
die amerikaner haben sich jetzt relativ
schnell und relativ überraschend
wahrscheinlich auch für die kunden
zurück gezogen war das naiv dass man
sich auf sie verlassen hat das hat ja
das erste mal dass die amerikaner die
kunden unterstützt haben und dann gesagt
habe so sache erledigt wir sind dann
wieder draußen es war definitiv nicht
naiv es gab keine andere lösung dh die
amerikaner haben viel dazu beigetragen
mit ihren alle mit ihren partnern das
der esc da ich besiegt ist der
amerikaner haben für stabilität gesorgt
in der region
aber das ist schon war das
präsidentenamt den lokalen partnern
praktisch hat seine lokalen partner
verraten
ich glaube nicht dass die amerikanische
administration der die amerikanische
bevölkerung damit einverstanden ist aber
wir haben einen präsidenten zu tun im
weißen haus der alle alle fünf minuten
seine meinung ändert und das war keine
gute entscheidung aber damit muss man
leben
was können denn jetzt die kurden in der
region auch die kurdischen milizen
überhaupt noch machen jetzt wo sie quasi
freiwillig das feld räumen mussten weil
ihm klar war das können wir hier nicht
überstehen wo gehen die hin was ist
ihnen jetzt quasi überhaupt noch an
tätigkeiten ja möglich sie versuchen
neue partnerschaften einzugehen mit den
russen zum beispiel ist ein dialog
gestartet worden mit damaskus wie wir in
badra gehört haben die syrischen
soldaten haben jetzt die kontrolle an
der grenze übernommen
das heißt die kunden versuchen weiterhin
mit den amerikanern
ds zu bekämpfen aber auf der anderen
seite versuchen sie lösungen zu finden
wie die wie die zukunft sein wird für
die region weil an einem an einem chaos
ist niemand interessiert und da muss man
weiterhin versuchen lösungen zu finden
damit die menschen dort weiterhin den
frieden und instabilität leben können
aber so ein bisschen habe ich das gefühl
ist der gast aus schon in der region da
auch wenn ich erst mal die kommentare
das auch so ein bisschen chaos
zum beispiel gibt es hier auf periskop
kommentare die sagen das sind keine
kurdischen kämpfer weil viele kurden
unterstützen auch die gpg nicht sie
möchten bewusst die kurden spalten heißt
es also dass auch innerhalb der
kurdischen community gar nicht so klar
ist auf wessen seite man steht und was
man überhaupt möchte
es gibt natürlich auch eine kurdische
opposition den kurdischen national
congress deren vertreter sind hier in
genf dabei den verfassungs gespräche sie
aber jetzt wo krieg herrscht gibt es
denke ich schon eine einigkeit darüber
dass man die angriffe der türkei
verurteilte niemand ist für den krieg
auch die opposition ist gegen die
türkisch angriffe das heißt zurzeit kann
man da nicht unterscheiden zwischen
opposition und zwischen der der der
richtigen machthaber vor ort der stf und
der y de weil in kriegszeiten rücken die
menschen zusammen und alle sind
betroffen
die opposition sie lebt auch in syrien
sie lobt auch in syrien und das heißt
wir kriegen betrifft auch sie und
deswegen ist die opposition auch gegen
den krieg und die opposition er hofft
auch dass der krieg endlich aufhört und
dass die kurden und mit ihnen auch die
christen und jahr aber in der region
endlich
eine durch die internationale
gemeinschaft beschützt wird
das sagen sie was ganz spannend ist denn
sie haben schon erwähnt also da wohnen
ja nicht nur kunden sondern auch
christen bei wurden araber da wurden
viele verschiedene volksgruppen zusammen
aber es gab ja zumindest von den kunden
immer so dieses diesen wunsch dass man
eine autonomie region innerhalb von
syrien bildet das geht schon in im irak
da sind die kurden quasi autonomen haben
sogar ein eigenes militär die peschmerga
und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
wollen dass die kunden in nordsibirien
genauso aber da muss man doch auch
fragen warum denn eine kurdische
autonomieregion länder auch andere volks
minderheiten leben dann könnte ja auch
sagen können sie eine christliche
autonomieregion geben also dieses
projekt war es jetzt im nordosten
syriens vorhanden ist ist kein
kurdisches volk das ist ein projekt an
dem kurden araber und christen beteiligt
sind also es gibt überhaupt keinen kein
wunsch nach einer kurdischen lösung es
gibt die meisten menschen wollen eine
gemeinsame lösung für alle ethnischen
und religiösen gruppen in der region
weil wir haben gemeinsame probleme und
diese probleme können wir nur gemeinsam
lösen und das ist denke ich auch der
gute ansatz für die zukunft kann es denn
der gemeinsame lösung mit der regierung
assad geben
wir hoffen dass es eine gemeinsame
lösung gibt aber da muss die regierung
ersatz sich ändern es muss die regierung
muss zulassen dass die verfassung
geändert wird dass sie dass die menschen
in der region
rechte in der verfassung wieder finden
dass die institutionen sich ändern dass
es dass der staat demokratischer werte
dass die dass es freie wahlen gibt
ich denke schon dass das viel potenzial
gibt aber die regierung regierung in
damaskus muss erstmal wollen
jetzt stellt sich aber doch so ein
bisschen die frage ob das für den ganz
normalen menschen der dort leben noch
sehr um sein überleben kämpfen muss
teilweise ja jetzt auch tatsächlich so
wichtig ist ist den leuten tatsächlich
dieser politische prozess so wichtig
dass sie sagen das ziehen wir jetzt
durch oder möchten die nicht einfach
frieden haben ganz egal wer jetzt an der
macht ist also ich berichte zurzeit aus
genf und ich bin im ständigen kontakt
mit meinen team vor ort
die menschen interessieren sich zurzeit
nicht an den politischen prozesse sie
wollen dass der krieg dass die
türkischen angriffe aufhören
sie wollen dass sie weiter in frieden
leben und sie wollen dass es eine lösung
gibt
eine dauerhafte lösung keine
kurzfristige lösung aber zurzeit sind
die russen da der das regime ist da die
amerikaner sind da die türken sind da
der iran hat seine finger im spiel
das 1 1 riesen chaos und die menschen
wollen endlich klarheit und ein normales
leben mehr wollen sie zurzeit nicht sie
hat ziemlich verständlich was ist denn
jetzt so als letzte frage ihr ansatz wo
sie denken damit könnte man am meisten
erreichen es gibt jetzt pläne von einer
un schutzzone dass dort die un reingeht
es gibt vorschläge aus deutschland dass
sie die eu doral reingeht und versucht
das ganze auseinanderzuhalten
ist das überhaupt realistisch oder
müssen sich die kunden dort und die
anderen minderheiten einfach damit
anfreunden dass sie mal wieder zwischen
den großen globalen nächten zerrieben
worden sind und jetzt den kürzeren
ziehen
also in der region traut niemandem traut
niemand mehr den russen dem regime den
amerikanern den türken sowieso nicht das
heißt es ist schon wünschenswert dass
die europäische union dort präsent ist
und versucht in eine art schutzzone für
dauerhaften frieden zu sorgen
wir brauchen schon eine einen
europäischen beitrag im nordosten
syriens anders geht es nicht weil sieht
so aus dass die russen nur die
amerikaner bis jetzt weder daran
interessiert sind oder noch die
möglichkeit haben dort eine dauerhafte
lösung zu präsentieren
wir bleiben auf jeden fall dran sie
hören heute in vielen dank für ihre zeit
heute abend nach genf und wir sind
gespannt was bei diesem prozess
rauskommt und an euch auch vielen dank
fürs zu gucken und für eure fragen und
kommentare für sind nächste woche wieder
für euch da mit dem nächsten stream bis
dahin sage ich und tschüss
[Musik]
und wenn ich das schien gefallen hat und
ihr mehr wissen möchte zum thema syrien
dann klickt doch mal hierher gibt es im
ganzen schienen dazu oder ganz anderes
thema
hier unsere stream zum thema was macht
youtube eigentlich mit kindern und
vergesst nicht natürlich uns ein tabu da
zu lassen